what is some of the most cursed [ __ ] you
have seen on youtube
i'm i'm actually curious now because i i
know it's probably honestly the most
cursed thing i've seen
it's pro it's pretty cursed it's pretty
[ __ ] up there i mean that that is
that is definitely up there but
if we're talking like classic like
cursed content like uh you guys never
watched uh
no you've ever watched like pizza time
never seen that one
no what's that it's this video
from like i don't even know when it's
made sounds familiar but it's basically
these like
a bunch of dudes like uh you watch
teenage mutant ninja turtles right
yeah you know how they're like obsessed
with pizza yeah so it's basically like a
a [ __ ] post on that but it's basically
this like explaining it is so weird but
it's basically just like a bunch of
dudes dressed up in ninja turtle cosplay
and then they like whip out their like
fake dicks and like
jack off onto this like pizza what
have you not seen it no this is this is
on youtube
it's on youtube wait i gotta know
are they australian american i have no
idea no the video is silent that's the
that's the most cursed thing about it
yeah the entire video is silent
and it's easily the most i don't even
remember your own soundtrack yeah i
don't even remember where i [ __ ] saw
it but like it was one of those like you
know [ __ ] cursed content that made
his
rounds on you know it's like [ __ ] yeah
yeah spinning that kind of [ __ ] right
but it was on youtube instead of her own
dedicated website i feel like you don't
really have
intentions don't look it up yeah yeah
please don't literally see it
often is the way it used to be i don't
know it used to be like kind of a like
bonding experience yeah you'd watch
cursed content
but now it doesn't feel that much now
just things like i feel like everyone
thinks you're a [ __ ] weirdo
if you watch that [ __ ] i mean it's kind
of true though
it doesn't matter if you do it on your
own or do it as a group it's still weird
yeah
i mean it's i mean i remember when
youtube went through the point where
pretty much you can you can say anything
was a prank and just like
and just get away with it like just just
physically assault someone and call it a
prank
the [ __ ] was his name uh uh what's this
scent no
sam pepper oh god you remember that guy
uh what was it
he used to be an iron streamer as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah he did the prank oh
yeah where he uh
killed his best friend yeah wait what do
you remember that have you seen that one
so he
actually did a prank where he would
kidnap one of us two of his friends
right
and then he would pretend to kill one of
them in front of the other friend and it
was a prank
it was like just like are you serious
this is a thing yeah this is a huge deal
huge yeah people people will honestly
ask about it i'm rightly so
yeah that sounds it's pretty [ __ ] up
and it's like
and it's like in the video like you just
see this like dude like in a [ __ ]
like bag over his head just like getting
fake shot
right what and the guy this is a black
mirror episode
and the other friend is like strapped to
the championship [ __ ] breaking down
crying
and he's like that's just a prank bro
you just thought his best friend got
murdered so of course naturally your
natural response is to freak the [ __ ]
out yeah
just mentally skilled my best friend for
life haha just the prank bro mostly
it was [ __ ] well it reminds me of that
um like the recent news that broke where
someone actually
got shot or got murdered in america or
something because
they were filming like a prank video
right oh that's right and they were like
approached
i think they were like fake mugging
people yeah really
yeah yeah there was this guy i can't
remember the exact details of the story
but there was this kid or something
who like was just pretending to mug
people or like yeah
i'm taking your money the ukulele
there's a guy in the background i mean
you know
like there's unfortunately more than one
body and now when it comes to youtube
pranks gone wrong or whatever
yeah wait wait so what happened to the
guy what getting like well
oh
[Music]
you're literally in america everyone has
a gun yeah i mean it's not even just in
america in any [ __ ] country
what what can you expect you just pull a
[ __ ] knife